眠いよ今日は朝50肇社長ですけど寝れなくて気づいたらず50になってました皆さん
ペット飼ってると言いますでしょうかまあ実家に住んでて意味とかネコとか買ってる方
多いと思うんですけどもあの僕も小さい子どものころは家にジョンってゆうげんがいた
んです柴犬のちょ
けどあの僕を見ると上にまいり
ほれ出荷3疲れるしでちょっと大嫌いだったんですけどあのさー最近のユーチューバー
もうあのな屋根でこうやれ
ね目小屋ねねこ猫ネコねこぺこなんですよ
俺も猫回転けどあの黒板の知ってると眠く無責任なんでえっと改定という気持ちで
ペットを飼っても多分お世話できないということがわかってるし大この a 高い月
基本的にペット禁止って大家さんが言ってた気をご利用しすればいけるんかな
1ちゃーはんじゃああーかないですまんちゃん帰って来てもはんじゃないですかたけど
ミント軍ターンしていればひょっとしたら帰るのかもしれねえけどちょっと近所忙しく
てペットを飼えねぇだと思って買ってないんですけどもやっぱりペット書いてんだよ
ちっちゃいにゃんじゃんかいてかわいいわぁも書いて
ちょっと変えないんです一人暮らししてる人わかると思うんですけどそんな余裕ないん
ですよペット帰って短時間まであと飼う資格もねあちゅありなんですのは僕はペット
ハードされてタイプだたんだよろしくオンナ哀しい26歳男性にですねえっ度を買わ
なくてもペットを飼っている気持ちになれる素晴らしいロボットが出たらしいので買っ
てきました
こちらめっちゃでかいんですけどこれ前
[音楽]
頑張って
パッケージのインパクトが強い心おやつシッポクッションこれまあクッションっぽく
見えるんですけどもこれ実はロボットなんです裏を見てみましょうたい今度空母って
言うんですねえっ久保は撫でると七宝振って応えてくれる
クッション型セラピーロボットですねこれロボットなんですよね
まあこいつどう見てもロボットで言って完全に空
ちゃんなんですけどもなぜも中身だけじゃないかこれ蛯子っぽくないですかね
うわーこ
冬めちゃまんまめっちゃそのまま入ってましたねすごいなぁもぱっと見ただの歯1本目
でクッションなんですけどもう公明てロボットらしいでちょっと上げてみましょうか
いやまいてんだもう眠いし疲れているし癒されたいしてたらうよちょっと本当にねワン
ちゃんこれで打っとかっている気持ちになれるんだったら俺はこれでいいよもう
ん
me
なんか
グローインで大丈夫これまあまあ細かいことは言わんけど大丈夫これはてくれば
ジッパージッパーダウンでこれねえ
中にロボット入ってこれがロボットカバンなんか見たくなかったなぁこれはほん大発見
なーんかやな感じでよし
これ本当にねっ
あっっえって動くんじゃないの
[音楽]
ん
me
またダウンを得ない帰るんだよ互換な滝国だがすごいですねだからすごいマットこの
抱き込むつの良い子の入ったクッションですねを選んですねこれ
me
[音楽]
おあああああああ
bef 2
すごいすごいめっちゃ動く
バシャバシャ場所はしちゃったこのすごいてくれたね
[音楽]
ブーバーし
また
いやー来ないよこんな早くれるの良い
ええええこれちょっとかわいいなやさしい比べると不わーいとしっぽの動きみたいです
ね
ただこの子さっきを見たと思うんですけども一級塾撫でるとこい
スーパーん
water me
ねぇめっちゃ可愛いし癒されますねこれはあえてこのロボットまた僕の後輩で知らない
奴がいると思うんで今ちょっと朝に出てるんですよねって部それぞれの近くにこれを
置いといて動くとはないわけじゃないですか尻尾ってどういう反応するのか見てみよう
と思いますではいきましょう
結構よ
[音楽]
なおん
なお
花王
[音楽]
ん
なおん
[音楽]
nomore
タウンた大パワーバー were true
ブーン
フープ
俺なぜ今とでは違いな恐怖くる
まあ出ると動くねー
やっぱクッションの造語クッ
うんすごいんです